[Music]
foreign
PhD she describes herself as not just a
normal physicist but an afro-latinx
physicist which means that her physics
are far more inclusive and Equitable
than regular physics this is the pitch
she makes for herself and her bio on her
website where she describes her
professional Mission this way she says
as one of the few afro-latinx women to
graduate from Saint Mary's University
with a Bachelor of Science in electrical
engineering and applied physics and the
second to graduate from with a PhD in
physics from Syracuse University Dr
esquival understands traversing spaces
as the only and has a very personal
recognition of the importance of equity
diversity and inclusion
she traverses spaces as the only
I could not possibly come up with a
better way to summarize leftist thought
each individual thinks of themselves as
indeed the only the only what well just
the only
then of course the other Hallmark of
leftist thought especially when it comes
to academics is that these thoughts are
communicated in the worthiest clunkiest
least eloquent most awkward way possible
hence the phrase traversing spaces
Dr esquive all PhD doesn't simply walk
across a room she traverses a space
so if you're sitting across the table
from her at a dinner table uh she won't
ask you to pass the salt she'll beseech
you to convey the sodium chloride from
its current position to an approximate
location near to where she is physically
located in space
and you must heed her request
immediately given that she is after all
the only the one and only
anyway the one and only Dr Esky of all
PhD makes it into the cancellation today
because of her recent Ted Talk focused
on what she calls the queer universe Dr
eskeval PhD has apparently noticed that
her far left comrades are having a very
difficult time using biological science
to formulate a coherent defense of queer
Theory and gender ideology so she
proposes that they abandoned that
Pursuit and instead seek validation and
Vindication in the field of quantum
physics
if gender ideology appears to make no
sense from a biological perspective
maybe she can make sense of it from a
physics perspective
and if she can't make sense of it at
least she hopes she can confuse people
enough to fool them into believing that
she made sense of it that seems to be
the goal of this talk titled the queer
Universe a Quantum explanation
so let's watch as much of it as we can
bear
queer
differing in some way from what is usual
or normal
Society we tend to think in absolutes
black or white
gay or straight male or female
but what if I were to tell you that the
universe is non-binary
that from cosmological State scales to
subatomic scales that the universe is
actually super queer
so it isn't such a crazy leap to assume
that everything inside our universe is
also clear
does that make you uncomfortable
or are you cautiously optimistic that
the universe may offer some comfort
my name is Dr Jessica scavelle I'm a
black Mexican queer neurodivergent woman
I'm also a particle physicist and today
leveraging my expertise on the
intricacies of the quantum realm we are
going to create a re-imagining of our
universe
now I have to say that if nothing else I
appreciate the visuals here a
blue-haired woke physicist blabbering
about the queer Universe to an empty
Stadium while a small group of people
walk around behind her completely
ignoring her she did say she's the only
after all in this case she's the only
one who attended her own lecture nobody
also no no notice also how she is
ostensibly preparing to give a talk
about science and yet while listing her
credentials her status as a physicist is
listed last after woman black Mexican
queer and neurodivergent
but if she has any legitimate scientific
insights to offer why does it matter
which alleged marginalized victim group
she belongs to what relevance does that
have
it's hard to imagine a legitimate
physicist beginning a speech by
announcing his sexual orientation
like I wasn't around to hear it myself
but I'm gonna I'm gonna guess that
Albert Einstein never opened a lecture
by saying my name is Albert Einstein I'm
a white cisgender heterosexual
neurodivergent german-born theoretical
physicist
that's because Einstein had brilliant
ideas and he was interested in letting
his ideas stand or fall on their own
merits Dr esquive all PhD on the other
hand needs to prop up her ideas on the
crutch of victimhood
let's keep listening
everything around us
everything from the galaxies filled with
stars
to the extraordinary depths of our
oceans filled with creatures beyond our
wildest dreams are made up of a
fundamental set of particles
these Teensy tiny particles live and
interact in a world unlike our own
in our macro world
we tend to think binary categorizations
and absolutes are the norm
but if we tunnel down into the smallest
spaces of our universe we enter a world
where queerness and Chaos reign supreme
on the contrary Dr Esquivel PhD uh you
don't need to go down to the bottom of
the ocean or look under a microscope to
see a world where queerness and Chaos
reign supreme that's actually a good
description of our culture queerness and
Chaos Reigns Supreme and yet if she's
right the queerness Reigns Supreme at
the most basic level of reality if
indeed the universe is Queer as she says
that doesn't that mean that queerness
doesn't exist
if queer means abnormal and yet the
abnormal is normal then there is no
abnormal if the universe is queer then
nothing is queer
in order for a thing to be abnormal it
must as she says in the beginning differ
from what is normal
which means that there has to be a
normal for the abnormal thing to differ
from
well you know established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of Lord or
lady and gain the respect that you so
richly deserve all you need is a one
square foot plot of land in Scotland and
when you do that you get your title pack
where you'll be bestowed with at least
one square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate in edelston Scotland plus
an official certificate which I have in
my hand that has a special Crest as you
can see your certificate features a
unique plot Number with which you can
see the exact location of your land you
can even visit it I think don't quote me
on that uh it's only a square foot so I
don't know what you do you just stand
there I guess title packs from
established titles are a fun and unique
gift for any occasion there are even
couple packs that come with adjoining
plots of land for that special someone
in your life with your certificate you
could officially add the prefix of Lord
or lady to your credit cards plane
tickets and even your dating profile
established titles told me that the
first 200 people that purchased title
pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within walking distance
of mine depending on how many of you uh
want to become a lord or lady we can
begin to build our own Kingdom together
established titles is actually running a
massive Black Friday sale right now and
if you use the code wall should check
out you'll get an additional 10 off so
go to established titles.com Walsh to
get your gifts now and help support the
channel
so as always you know they want to have
their queer cake and eat it too she
wants to
proudly announce herself as queer taking
pride in her own abnormality and yet in
the next breath insists that she is not
abnormal at all because in fact
everything is queer everything is gay
everything is non-binary even the atoms
are gay
our entire universe is comprised of gay
particles she says
this is obviously totally inane
pseudo-scientific New Age Babble but
it's also self-contradictory
ever since the days of Alfred Kinsey the
priests and priestesses of the sexual
Revolution have tried desperately to
convince us that their lifestyle choices
and sexual quirks are actually normal
and yet at the same time they also want
to cling to their victimhood card and
their identity as a supposedly oppressed
minority so they want to be a minority
and the majority at the same time
now I won't inflict much more of this on
you but let's hear how she wraps all
this up
all matter is a peculiar conundrum that
we don't quite understand
even confounding still
even though all mattered in the universe
including atoms molecules humans plants
planets galaxies oceans
all of that only consists of five
percent of the visible matter that we
can see in our universe five percent
so the rest of it is dark energy and
dark matter and that's another
confounding topic for another talk
but all this to say that
it is an existential fact that we are
anomalies in our universe and the most
existential question at the heart of my
research is not if we are queer but why
we are queer
and I wonder
if we were to let the chaos of quantum
mechanics infiltrate our thinking if we
were to let go of those rigid processes
we have and become one with the queer
universe
I wonder maybe possibly
scientific discoveries would become
easier
you know this woman
spent like six years in college came out
with a doctorate and all of that just so
that she could tell us to become one
with the queer universe
I could not possibly think of a better
argument against student loan
forgiveness than that
now has she achieved her aim with this
lecture well
if her aim was to somehow prove that
non-binary and transgender identities
are valid by prattleing on about queer
subatomic particles then no she has not
the fact that particles behave strangely
and unexpectedly does not legitimize the
illogical and biologically impossible
self-perceptions of human beings
subatomic particles can do lots of
things that entire human beings cannot
do that can pass through solid objects
for instance
Dr esque ball PhD is here taking a
common leftist tactic to extraordinary
and extraordinarily stupid lengths where
you know they often attempt to prove
that a person's self-identity and their
self-identity claim is legitimate by
drawing a comparison to a phenomenon
that occurs outside of the human species
so just last week we heard from someone
who attempted to prove that the sex
binary among human beings is false
by pointing to the fact that some
organisms like amoebas exist outside of
the sex binary like amoebas are asexual
they reproduce asexually
that's supposed to prove something about
that's supposed to validate amoebas
validate a claim that a man addresses
making about them no because who human
beings are not amoebas and though human
beings are comprised of like zillions of
sub atomic particles a human being is
not a subatomic particle individually
but there's more important point to be
made here I think
which is to note
how small and diminished everything
becomes when it's filtered through queer
Theory or gender ideology or whatever
you want to call it I mean physics is a
fascinating field I don't understand any
of it
but I do know that it can unlock and has
has unlocked some of the deepest
Mysteries of the universe the more you
understand physics the more you
understand the nature of the world of
the cosmos of reality and yet this woman
being an adherent to the LGBT religion
isn't interested in the secrets of the
universe the only Universe she cares
about is the universe of her own small
fragile ego
so rather than taking the tools of the
tool of physics and directing it out
into the world to understand and explore
she pointed back at herself
to obsess over and justify her own
personal and sexual preoccupations
the result is the nonsense you just
heard but worse than being merely
nonsense it's also boring and
uninteresting and dull and irrelevant
I suspect there's probably a fair amount
of nonsense offered by theoretical
physicists
but at least the nonsense is usually
fascinating and directed towards the
pursuit of something greater something
Noble you know understanding the
universe
This Woman's nonsense on the other hand
is the result of trying to jam physics
into a space under the umbrella of queer
Theory
she's trying to subordinate it bring it
to heal
fit it into a hierarchy where lgbt's
self-interest stands at the very top
and this is what happens more and more
as institutions and scientific fields
are ideologically captured by the far
left they end up churning out a whole
bunch of bogus garbage and worse than
that they stop pursuing truth they stop
looking for it
because they're too busy looking in the
mirror
talking to themselves
and that is why Dr esquival PhD
is today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as you move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]